while billions of stars are scattered
throughout the universe the one at the
center of our solar system
plays a special role for us here on
earth
our sun formed about 4.5 billion years
ago in the milky way galaxy's orion spur
it was born when a cloud of dust and gas
known as a solar nebula collapsed and in
the middle of this formation matter
condensed into a burning ball of gas
that became our sun
the sun's fiery nature along with a
tremendous gravitational pull and an
extensive magnetic field helped it to
become the heart of our solar system
the sun can be divided into six layers
or regions the corona
the chromosphere
the photosphere
the convective and radiative zones
and the core
in terms of atom count the sun is about
91 hydrogen the sun's fuel 8.9 helium
and 0.1 heavier elements such as carbon
and nitrogen
[Music]
due to the sun's extreme temperatures
these elements stay in a gas-like phase
called plasma
in the core
temperatures reaching at least 27
million degrees fahrenheit combined with
the sun's powerful gravity fuse together
hydrogen molecules to create helium
called thermonuclear fusion this
releases an enormous amount of energy in
the form of radiation electricity
solar wind and as we experience on earth
life-giving heat and light
such volatility is contained thanks to
the sun's tremendous gravity
it's strong enough to hold the solar
system intact and is primarily due to
the sun's size and mass
our sun is the largest and most massive
object in the solar system
it's more than 100 earths wide
and could theoretically fit all eight
planets inside
nearly 600 times
it also contains approximately 99.8
percent of all the mass in the solar
system
because of this mass the sun has a great
pull on the fabric of space
creating a gravitational force that
causes nearby planetary bodies to be
drawn toward it this gravitational pull
allows the sun to hold together a system
of eight planets potentially dozens of
dwarf planets at least 170 moons and
countless comets and asteroids
without the sun's gravity these
celestial bodies would drift off into
deep space
[Music]
another critical property of the sun is
its magnetic field which encapsulates
the entire solar system
called the heliosphere this force field
protects the planets from harmful cosmic
radiation
it's caused by the sun's plasma pushing
electrically charged particles toward
the star's poles
this process turns the sun into a giant
magnet
although the sun's magnetic field is
invisible to the naked eye
its effects are noticeable
on the sun's surface are dark areas
called sunspots which mark strong
pockets of magnetism
on earth and on some of the other
planets the sun's magnetic field
interacts with their atmospheres
resulting in beautiful auroras
despite its size and strength the sun
will not last forever
in about 6.5 billion years it will run
out of its hydrogen fuel expand to
envelop mercury venus and even earth and
then collapse into a small star known as
a white dwarf
in the meantime the sun will continue to
play a critical role in the system that
bears its name
the sun's protective magnetic field
tremendous gravitational pull and
ability to create vast amounts of energy
will protect contain and give life to
our solar system
[Music]
you